ministre indien multi garçons où tout
n'a pas toujours été rose pour lui sa
vie était très difficile il a été
malmenés bousculés dispersé né d'un père
très violent d'une mère pauvre femme de
ménage elle a dû laisser ses six enfants
des inconnus afin de fuir la mort que
lui tendait le père au fils des années
qui défilent
le petit garçon a du spla est placé à la
dass il a connu plusieurs familles
pas d'internet pas de téléphone même pas
un poisson rouge dans un bocal pas
d'amis l'avaient pu consolation son seul
repère un crayons et des feuilles de
papier pour dessiner ses rêves son futur
c'est plus grand désir mais c'était sans
compter sur les épreuves qui
l'accompagnaient il s'est mis à courir
il court il court aussi loin qu'il peut
mais quand une personne court tout le
monde se met à courir et puis en cours
est en cours en copeaux échapper ce ce
qu'on ne veut pas ce qu'on n'aime pas ce
qu'on ne veut pas affronter ce qui fait
peur ce qui est trop lourd à porter ce
qu'on ne veut pas connaître
et puis puis en cours et puis on regarde
devant et puis un petit mur qui encore
tout petit mais qui est encore sans
importance parce qu'on ait cette
distance est en fait ce qui est encore
plus important qui nous tient captifs
derrière mais en même temps on veut
avancer en est sous la seule voie où il
ya un brin de soleil
de toute façon c'est la seconde qui
éclaire et bourru rocheuses peu importe
mais c'est une voie qui a suffisamment
dégagé pour échapper
à ceux qui nous ya pas de nom c'est
juste difficile à supporter et puis en
cours puis on avance puis ce mieux
qu'ils étaient tout petits qui n'avaient
pas d'importance et qui a grossi
subitement qu'on s'approche et puis là
on commence à ralentir et on s'essouffle
à bout de souffle a le coeur qui bâille
et puis la bo face au mur en général un
mur et source d'arrêt total mur c'est là
où on se dit on peut plus avancer et un
obstacle on n'a pas de solution
on sait pas à qui parler ou se reposer
la tête et j'ai mis longtemps à
comprendre cela et en fait le mieux
n'est pas là pour nous empêcher
d'avancer mais en fait pour nous
empêcher ou plus ou moins pour à ce
qu'on puisse s'arrêter de courir et
apprendre à régler ce qui est derrière
est visé ce qui est devant on ne peut
pas faire les deux à la fois parce que
physiquement si en cours la tête comme
ça là on va trébucher
on va se cogner le pied il faut régler
ce qu'il ya derrière et puis avancez et
puis là finalement je me suis dit stop
là j'en ai marre je fais jamais rien de
bien dès que j'ai fait du bien c'est mal
quand c'est mal tu feras jamais rien de
bon
tu seras jamais comme les autres tout ce
que tu fais ça tu repars presqu'à j'ai
pas droit à ma place sur la terre mais
moi j'y réfléchis précoce puisque jeunes
dans la souffrance il faut réfléchir
vite puisque le temps ça passe vite
j'ai pris ce mur et j'en ai fait mon
ardoise
ma feuille de match mon cahier un dessin
là où je pouvais écrire mon futur est ce
qu ici ma vie lui donner un sens mais
facile à dire mais pas facile
faire puisque les épreuves c'est
difficile tout le monde en a mais
comment faire ça là où tout est
compliqué on est sans cesse bombardé
d'image de clips de films de telenovelas
de films d'action de super héros et
petit à petit au fur à mesure on regarde
en observer il chante bien il joue bien
je m'identifie à lui je me dis tiens
puisqu'on a le même milieu on vient du
même ghetto haut du même château
peut-être que je vois le même la même
vie puisque on vient du même milieu
et puis petit à petit je me croise comme
lui je chante comme lui je parle comme
lui je bois comme lui je vis comme lui
et inconsciemment on s'est mis une image
qui n'est pas nous qui n'est pas moi qui
n'ai pas 3 et on se dit tiens mais war
est un problème j'ai copié une image
j'ai un clic et un habit qui n'est pas
moi c'est quelque chose que j'ai vu est
en fait en s'oublier on est en train de
profilés l'image de l'autre lui donner
son futur dégager son chemin
il a plus rien à faire puisque c'est
nous c'est jardiniers et on s'oublie
dans tout cela à se cacher derrière une
image qui n'est pas nous c'est un peu
comme à l'école où on aimait bien marché
avec les équipes qui étaient plus forts
et si on était plus faible
ils nous couvrent est quel que soit ce
qu'on disait ben là je me suis dit qu'il
faut qu'on puisse apprendre à nous
connaître à nous saisir à plus ou moins
nous sont sondés nos échecs nos
victoires on doit être tous et toutes
inévitablement être une source
d'inspiration pour chacun d'entre nous
un homme a dit à jour rémi gaillard
c'est en faisant n'importe quoi qu'on
devient n'importe qui
quand il a dit ça je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il raconte
et si je donne un coup de poing à
quelqu'un est ce que je devient tout à
coup quelqu'un de célèbre mais bon et en
fait c'est vrai je vais vous raconter un
truc de fou c'est du n'importe quoi en
2006 je me suis rendu à la chambre des
métiers pour pouvoir créer mon
entreprise je voulais avancer grandir
avoir un futur tracé mon chemin et on me
donne la liste des documents et bon
quittance loyer mâchant et tout comme
d'habitude en échec que j'avais mais
sans provision les choses étaient durs
mais j'ai ramené quand même et puis
belle très belle dame à l'accueil
je pense qu'elle était fait pour ce
poste mais malheureusement elle me dit
que on peut pas vous immatriculer je dis
mais pourquoi voici tous les documents
oui mais vous n'avez pas l'examen n'est
pas de diplôme
puisqu'il faut avoir un diplôme aux
perdrix pour faire de la déco je dis ah
bon pourtant je sais dessinée voyez vous
même je suis reconnaître rose quand même
je sais ce que je fais mais selon vous
vous allez me donner votre avis si je
fais ça pouvez vous dire que je mérite
d'avoir même un c ap pourtant vous voyez
bien que j'ai juste fait de petits bars
et si je poursuis est ce que je me dis
que là je mérite un bac parce qu
apparemment plus on monte dans les
chiffres
puis on devait importants ont peut-être
si jamais le petit cela peut-être que
j'aurai un deug
je sais pas peut-être mais puis-je
continuer puis on m'a dit oui mais
comment pouvez-vous ne pas avoir de
diplôme est allé chercher des clients et
demain comment pouvez vous prouvez que
vous savez dessinée j'ai dit mais madame
vous savez enfin je sais pas pour les
autres métiers mais je pense que les
goûts et les couleurs ça ne se discute
pas mon meilleur cv c'est mon coeur
c'est mes émotions c'est ce que je sais
faire de mieux moi je ne sais pas aller
prendre un papier et pouvoir dire voilà
est-ce que je dois aller faire des
grandes études ont juste et connectée
dicks a besoin tout ça et au final avec
persistance
quand j'ai commencé finalement elle a dû
accepter parce que peut-être que j'ai su
que pointe à pitre avec une bombe
aérosol c'est c'est fou mais le monde et
il fait de choses y réalise parfois
réels
enfin on pourrait on pourrait dire ainsi
et finalement elle a accepté
elle a récupéré les documents et j'ai pu
avoir un numéro de siret des années
après et c'est comme ça là encore
d'autres murs qui ont été percées mais
j'ai pu savoir que les épreuves font
partie de notre vie
ils sont là pour nous forger nous
fortifier nous permettre de vendre
devant nous je viens de dire à tout à
l'heure à l'instant que soyons tous des
sources d'inspiration qui soit blanc
noir gros maigres grand petit givet
grenier rasta dreadlocks civelli ce
couillon tb boîte chabin chabine peu
importe on doit être et on est tous et
toutes les sources d'inspiration pour
chacun d'entre nous les charpentiers pu
être une source d'inspiration pour un
mécanicien ils n'ont pas le même métier
mais si le mécanicien lui les
démoraliser le charpentier avec son
esprit positif peut lui permettre de le
remettre sur les rails
pas besoin d'avoir le même métier la
même coiffure avoir le même design soit
toutes et tous une source d'inspiration
martin luther king a dit un jour je ne
m'inquiète pas de te voir tomber mais je
mets quête de te voir te relever et je
me suis dit là cet après midi où nous
sommes tous réunis
vous qui êtes toutes et tous à 6 là vous
avez tous un mur
inévitablement mais il jouait une seule
question qu'allez vous faire de votre
mur merci